we begin with breaking news out of
ethiopia the un says nine of its
staffers and their family members have
been detained in the capital adiz
and it's calling for their immediate
release it's not clear why they were
detained
let's get the latest from muhammad who
is live for us in addis ababa muhammad
what more do we know
well we know very little at this point
kim just that the u.n is confirming nine
of its workers here in this european as
well as their dependents who have been
detained
um un security officials have been to
see them uh in the
in their detention and they say that
they have sent a note vabal to the
ministry of foreign affairs calling for
their immediate release we do not know
exactly why they have been detained
government officials here are yet to
speak on the detention of these u.n
workers
but we know the un and european
government have had
an uneasy relationship in recent months
in september the government expelled
seven u.n workers who is accused
of meddling in its internal affairs uh
last month uh two u.n workers were
recalled after an audio recording of
some u.n
workers uh
accusing senior u.n officials in
ethiopia of sympathizing with the tigray
rebels went online um so but we don't
know exactly why they have been arrested
and and their dependents as well
okay i know we are expecting a press
briefing not in the not too distant
future from the u.n in the meantime
muhammad just explain to our viewers the
background to this the the tplf fighters
making their way south concerns that
this conflict could really escalate
yes it has escalated in recent weeks
the conflict has now spilled over to the
and afar regions where ethiopian defense
forces assisted by irregular combatants
from uh
militias to offer militia as well as
thousands of civilians who've taken up
arms in response to a call by prime
minister abi ahmed for ethiopians to
defend their country against the rebels
um and they said that they're saying now
that their lines have been holding for
the past few days and the rebels on
their side are saying that they've been
forced to march towards addis ababa in a
bid to break the siege on the tigray
regional siege that has caused
you know a humanitarian crisis of huge
proportions more than four hundred
thousand people are living in
famine-like conditions millions others
are food insecure and there is now a
frantic diplomatic effort mainly
language by the african union through
its horn of africa special envoy former
president of nigeria olusegun obasanjo
who has said that he will have a plan
for dialogue by the end of the week
the u.s state department says it's
working with the african union in trying
to bring about a ceasefire agreement and
an end to the conflict in ethiopia
through dialogue of course the united
nations also has been trying to
pile pressure on the ethiopian
government and also the rebels trying to
bring them together but there has been
there has been an obstacle until now
which is um the tag the rebels have been
put on by the ethiopian government which
is
being put in
the list of terrorist organizations that
has been a hindrance to negotiations
starting between the parties we do not
know at this point whether the ethiopian
government is ready to drop the
terrorist tag it has
given to the tigray rebels but the prime
minister tweeting alia on today said he
is ready to work with ethiopia's friends
to find a solution to ethiopia's
temporary challenges as he put it
all right muhammad i'm sure we'll be
coming back to you when we get more
information on this developing story for
now thank you for that